uh how do you defend it looks like
you're going to win either the E6 Pawn
or the F5 pawn and there we go are we
going to see Prague start shaking his
head
no I yeah he must have some idea I mean
he must be banking on the
power of the night time thinking you
know that the Rook once it captures the
pool and the Knight will kind of spring
forward to the middle of the board yeah
but then you walk into him maybe yet
another thing in this position there we
go managerov has just won a pawn
remember this pin means The Rook is
taboo you cannot capture it and uh yeah
I think you're right I think he was
banking on this night coming forward
hitting the white Bishop maybe he
thought he could hit the pinning piece
but he forgot that the other Bishop the
other sleeping giant here could spring
forward and look at the power of these
Bishops suddenly
winning the game and Prague reacting
head in hands the problem is now if you
capture white Bishop your own Bishop
Falls and uh rook and Bishop worked
better than Rooker Knight as a combo but
also you have one